tunisia needs the support of
the european parliament in favor of a
greater involvement of the
european institutions on the technical and
financial levels today and in view of the
major challenges facing the country
this political process
should be protected and
democratic construction  consolidated in the
first place it is the challenge of
economic growth and employment that
we must take up the reasons which
caused the Tunisian revolution at the
end of 2010 at the beginning of 2011 are still there
they are still present
if my information is correct in
recent  weeks there have been more
causes without social conflicts that have
hit the most disadvantaged regions in particular
where it all started
it's true that these taxes were made
to bleed white from shopping in the states
journalist and activist said to guy
caillonce  too chilly this liberal the
firing position we are
fundamentally against against against
any military action